a subscriber has challenged me to a
stargate quiz
so let's see how i do
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv the
movie channel
so a subscriber has challenged me here
sent me a link to a quiz on stargate sg1
and he said if i do not get 100
then i can no longer call myself an sg1
fan and i should delete my channel
immediately
so
no pressure
so here we go here's the quiz i'll put a
link to it on the description but i'm
going to read all the questions and the
answers anyway so
um
but please i'm going to
play along with me please and let's see
how we get on so the quiz is on
how stuff works it's supposed to take
about four minutes it's been written by
the staff
um i have not looked at any of the
questions i have just seen the first
question and it's really easy so let's
hope the quiz gets a little bit more
difficult as you go along but hey let's
get stuck into it and uh again
it's just my entire channel that rests
on it
so first question what is the title of
the premiere episode of the series
stargate sg1 the enemy within
emancipation or children of the gods
children of the gods correct answer
children's of god's first edge july 27th
1997
television series sg-1 is based on the
feature film stargate what where year
was the movie released
oh crap
it was a couple of years after i think
it was three years after sg-1 came out
so the answer the choices are 1992 1994
or 1996.
gonna go in 1994.
correct answer stargate released in the
us on october 28th 1994. two for two the
channel lives
true or false stalker sg1 was first
aired on show time not only was it first
aired on showtime it was actually
showtime's um biggest ever um premiere
at that point
true premiere of showtime which is the
first five seasons of the show
which network aired season six through
ten of the series
now i'm going to say that's in the
united states and i'm going to go with
the sci-fi network it's not usa network
and it's not fx so the sci-fi network
correct answer
right how many episodes of stargate sg1
did showtime order before the pilot
aired
this is going to trip me up
i've heard of this
i think
they might have ordered the first two
seasons
i think they ordered the first two
seasons so if the the options are 0 22
or 44. i'm going to go with 44 and oh
god i'm nervous on this one
correct answer showtime ordered another
44 episodes midway through the first
season
which character is the leader of the
sg-1 team in the television series
colonel o'neill lieutenant colonel
shepherd or colonel young
well
yeah come on in
correct answer
excellent which actor played the
character jack o'neill in the series
james spader richard dean anderson kurt
russell it's james bader no it didn't
obviously he played him in the movie
richard dean anderson correct answer he
was also in macgyver i didn't know that
he was in macgyver did you guys know
he's a macgyver
um i've just found a new series that he
was in actually a great subscriber um
sent me the message for this and it was
called legend and it only had like 12
episodes and actually um john de lancie
from um
star trek obviously q was in it as well
and it's like a western thing i've only
watched the first couple of episodes and
i don't think it ever came to the uk so
i've never seen it before but god is
brilliant
uh right which target sg1 character to
do michael shanks play in the tv series
um teal jonas queen or daniel jackson
this is getting a bit easy this quiz it
is daniel jackson
which of the following was not an
official tagline for the series
oh come on tagline that that's
right
was not an official
tagline of the for the series the only
mission is survival
unlock the universe or saving the world
one episode at a time it can't be saved
in the world one episode of the time can
it
can it
[Music]
no wrong answer i'm gonna have to delete
my whole channel oh god the only mission
is survival was not an official tagline
for the series it was however a tagline
for the spin-off series sgu
come on
ah that is crap
right the stunt coordinator for the
series target is g1 dan shea also played
what recurring character in the show
cronus sergeant seiler or martin lloyd
it was sergeant sila
um
one of the best episodes particularly
series two is the black hole episode and
you see sergeant styler gets smashed
when they're trying to cut the power for
the game
brilliant
um in which city was target 81
preliminary primarily filmed vancouver
and filming tumbling spending tolling
right most filming of the series was
doing a vancouver british columbia film
and television production spending total
more than 2 billion in 2014 has made
vancouver the third largest production
center in north america
which regular cast member also voiced
stargate sg-1's character for richard
anderson michael chance of christopher
judge now this is actually
michael shanks correct answer
who is the jaffa member of stargate sg-1
ba
braytac or teagulk t-hulk was the ant
which actually played the role of tealk
in the series christopher judge tony
ahmed
or coronemic karinamic obviously played
um
the characters whose names just got on
my head we mentioned him ago nevermind
and chris were just playing 19 episode
macgyver with his first target one he
was in macgyver as well who knew
in season eight who leads the sg1 team
when colonel neal is promoted daniel
jackson samantha carter or
colonel cameron mitchen cameron mitchell
what
i got that one wrong oh my god major car
response to the lieutenant colonel and
give him financial one colonel o'neal is
promoted to general and assumes command
of sg1
ah
mitchell doesn't come until series nine
ah what
oh i'm definitely gonna have to delete
the channel i wanna so i'm sorry guys by
the time you watch this video the
channel will be deleted
and which brand of use military is
stargate command a part of in the series
air force
true or false michael shanks's real life
illness was written into his character
in the series i'm going to go to
redemption here if i can tell you what
his actual illness was can i keep my
channel get in the comments and let me
know um
he had
an appendicitis burst i don't know
that's the proper name for that is it's
apparent but it's only like a couple of
days before filming started so they
basically just had him lying in a bed
for the series
correct answer before filming the
stargate episode nemesis actor michael
shouts defender developed appendicitis
to explain his absence the same illness
was written into the show for his
character
in which episode of target sg-1 did dr
frey should die heroes
the resurrection or the lost city part
one heroes part two
dr frazier was killed by a jaffa staff
blast this season he resumed the episode
aired in 2004
which actress played
um dr frasier in stargate sg1 lexa doig
uh michael shanks's wife claudia black
who's just
i haven't got a leather fetish but oh my
god um or um i don't even know how to
say her first name terrell tell rothery
it was terrell rothery she appeared in
75 episodes before
which character replaced daniel jackson
for one season
um of stargate sg1 jonas quinn that's
who i was trying to think of a minute
ago i couldn't remember his name it's
jonas queen
correct answer jonas queen
jackson died from radiation and then
returned naked letter leighton to to sit
jonas out
um which actually portrayed the
character jonas quinn it was cory nemec
who was i was trying to say earlier when
i was trying to remember his name
true or false the prop used for takra
memory devices target sg-1 is a nose
hair trimmer
oh
i don't know
i'm trying to remember what the memory
device looked like
i thought they stuck it on their heads
what you think what should i go for
i don't know this i'm gonna go true
correct answer hey
um we used to film completely unaltered
they didn't even change it to make it
look futuristic or if they just used it
i didn't know that that's amazing and
which target sg1 character did um beau
bridges play general hammond hank landry
or master braytac it was hank landry
hank we don't we don't really have the
name hank in the uk we should
uh generally understand command of
stargate one of general is promoted how
many symbols are used to open a stargate
it depends which series
stargate is usa
but the answer is actually seven
um which real world location is the
fictional home of stargate command mount
evans pikes peak or cheyenne mountain
cheyenne mountain
was home of norad is now home of space
command ghost please command
space force even ghost space force
um
which is the name of jack o'neill's son
ah crap charlie tommy or johnny i should
know this i think it's charlie isn't it
charlie died accidentally shot himself
what is the longest a stargate can stay
open uh 19 minutes 76 minutes or 38
minutes 38 minutes is that the correct
answer
how many spin-off series were inspired
by stargate sg-1
one two or three
stargate universe and stargate atlantis
true or false richard anderson appeared
in every episode of the series stagger
sg-1 false
christopher george and amanda tapping
are the only cast members to appear in
all 213 episodes of the series
when did the last stargate when did the
last episode of star gesture one air
right
it's the 25th anniversary of this year
so let's do the math
2007. so 2005 2006 or 2007 correct
answer
unending aired in june 27th your score
was 93 you are at your expert screw you
subscriber who said uh if i didn't get
100
um can i share a facebook no
so that is the quiz
please i've got the link stop recording
i got the link in there um i i think i
did okay i made one silly mistake
because i didn't think the question
through and i got a couple i got a
couple of guesses but you know i think i
did okay then um if you've got any
quizzes you think we should have a look
at please send me them in the in the
comments section let's have a look i'm
gonna actually have a stargate quiz at
some point as well i'd love to get a
couple of you guys on so if you're
interested please let me know
as usual guys if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit the
bell notification really helps us out
you can also become a fully fledged
sidetracker please consider hitting the
join button it really supports the
channel and you know
keeps it going really so
and as always please stay safe i'm going
to see you next time
[Music]
you